[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's very nice. Thank you
Someone said to me,
"You look young from far away.
[ Light laughter ]
And I think it might be
the worst compliment
I've ever heard...
[ Laughter ]
...in my life.
It has a real M. Night Shyamalan
twist at the end,
doesn't it?
[ Light laughter ]
"You look young."
"Yeah?"
"From far away."
"Wow!
I did not see that coming.
[ Laughter ]
You are mean from up close
is what you are.
[ Laughter ]
I...
I don't like you
from this distance.
I'm trying to stay young,
you know, and move.
We don't move enough.
Isn't that a weird
modern-day health concern?
But it's true.
Do you ever sit sedentary
for 36 hours and just go,
"Boy, I don't feel well
right now."
[ Laughter ]
I think
it's going to baffle historians.
"What happened to these people?"
"They just stopped.
We're not sure."
[ Laughter ]
"They kind of slowly coalesced
into a gel,
and that was it for them.
We have evidence that
they were actually countin
their individual steps
one at a time."
[ Laughter ]
"That's how little
they were moving."
[ Cheers and applause ]
My friends are into running.
And they say stuff like,
"I'm addicted to running,"
which I cannot
wrap my head around.
I am so addicted
to stopping running.
[ Laughter ]
I can't stop stopping running.
The whole time I'm running
all I'm thinking is,
"When does the addiction
kick in?"
[ Laughter ]
Most things that are addictive
take action quick,
but this running seems to be
a bit of an outlier --
can we agree?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you see people run
who are meant to run.
They look graceful
and efficient.
The whole time I'm running
there's this thought going
over and over in my head,
which is,
"I've never seen me run,
but I don't think
this looks right."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"One leg is doing far more wor
than it should.
I might be skipping right now.
I'm not certain."
[ Laughter ]
So...
[ Laughter continues ]
Little things are happening.
I fell down.
I used to trip.
[ Light laughter ]
Do you understand?
[ Laughter ]
Here's how life goes.
Tripping -- young.
Falling -- old.
[ Laughter ]
I fell down.
It was significant.
I'm calling it an adult fall
And I say that because
I remember as a child
adults talking to other adults
about falling
in very hushed, serious tones.
Do you remember
those conversations?
"Ryan, Grandma fell."
[ Light laughter ]
"Did you tell her to get up?
[ Laughter ]
"I fell six times.
It's not even noon.
What do you want from me?"
[ Laughter ]
But I understand now.
I have a little empathy.
I had my own adult fall.
I fell on the streets
of New York City.
People were around.
I mean, there was no denying it.
Everyone asked, "Are you okay?
Yes, but let me make
this point --
not everyone meant it.
That's true.
[ Laughter ]
Two 25-year-old girls
on the street go,
"[Chuckles] Are you okay?"
[ Laughter ]
I mean, there was...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Applause continues ]
...zero empathy
in their reaction.
The words
came out of their mouths.
What they
actually communicated was,
"I wish my camera was on
for that.
That was spectacular."
[ Laughter ]
"Are you okay?"
Has anyone ever answered, "No,
to, "Are you okay?"
in the history of falling down
My body was screaming
I was not okay,
and I still said, "I'm fine.
[ Laughter ]
"I want to die alone right here.
Put the orange cones around me
and leave me alone."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Are you okay?"
What am I supposed to say to two
25-year-old girls on the street?
"No, can you two petite children
take me to the hospital"?
[ Laughter ]
"What are you gonna do?
Go get a grown-up, quick."
[ Laughter ]
I was with a girl when I fell.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Let me just tell you
the whole story.
So, there we are.
We're at dinner.
We're enjoying
each other's company.
Over time, I thought
maybe we should date.
So I brought it up.
I said, "Maybe we should date.
She very kindly,
as gingerly as humanly possible,
said,
"Maybe we should not date.
[ Laughter ]
Now, it's okay.
I'm -- I'm happy to have
an honest conversation.
but then we left the restaurant,
and then I fell down.
And...
[ Laughter ]
Now...
[ Laughter continues ]
My only wish
for this whole scenario
is that there could have bee
a little space
between these two moments.
[ Laughter ]
That's all.
Just, does nobody have my back
Is there not one guardian ange
petitioning for me, going,
"Look, he threw
a curve ball at dinner.
Nobody saw that coming.
Is there any way that
we can push his adult fall
by just a day?"
And...
[ Laughter ]
...I can just hear God going
"You know, I would love to
but we've pushed this adult fall
as far as
we can possibly push it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm very sorry.
Everyone's in place.
There's simply nothing
I can do."
[ Laughter ]
"Anyway, he's gonna be fine.
He looks young from up here.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Ryan Hamilton.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
♪♪♪♪
-What? Oh, my God.
What a great set.
Ryan Hamilton!
That's a nice standing ovation
for you there, buddy.
Well done.
Ryan Hamilton.
For info on Ryan's fall tour
visit ryanhamiltonlive.com